hi I'm any call professor my name's from
the office of executive education at
singapore management university i had a
privilege of moderating the creating job
session and on the Entrepreneurship
equation it was a wonderful panel we had
great diversity on the panel and what we
came about this is tricky chicken wings
number one there is no rule alone for
the government to create jobs in order
to unleash potential in entrepreneurship
you need a partnership really both a
government as well as the private sector
working very closely with educational
institutes I think one of the big
challenges is a human capital Federation
many of the big eminences could not
fight skills and the challenge shortage
in running your companies in Asia so
therefore government alone that's not is
not sufficient we need to work with the
private enterprises to signal to the
universities and in conversation with
both the private and the government
sector on what skills are needed to
prepare the next generation of tablet in
addition we have founded in order to
unleash entrepreneurship we need to move
many of the micro enterprises from a
level of just many micro enterprises to
be SNP's slow medium enterprises that
have worked to the next level we have
marvell technology on mcconnell and
passing i was saying that before
environment the whole ecosystem in
indonesia has changed it has to engage
both institutions and the government and
the education sector in order to grow
that set on entrepreneurship skills we
are looking forward to more conversation
in this direction I think the journey
has just begun it has not been located
and are going to continue you have this
set of conversations in future World
Economic Policy nerves